si on savait qu'une naissance prévue
dans quelques mois qui va relancer le
débat bioéthique celle d'un bébé
spécialement conçu pour sauver son frère
atteint d'une leucémie cela se passe aux
etats-unis mais la famille et
britanniques
bonsoir axel kahn vous êtes généticien
membre du comité d'éthique vous nous
direz est ce que vous en pensez mais
d'abord les détails jean daniel
flaysakier laurent bout si adam nash est
né le 29 août 2000 aux états unis c'est
le premier bébé conçu dans un but précis
servir de donneur compatible de moelle
osseuse pour sa soeur molly atteinte
d'une grave maladie sanguine dans
quelques semaines l'histoire va se
répéter en angleterre les pieters ont un
fils marcus s'agit de quatre ans qui
souffre d'une leucémie
il peut avoir bientôt besoin d'une
greffe de moelle osseuse alors les
parents sont allés à chicago pour faire
ce que l'on appelle un diagnostic
préimplantatoire le principe on a
fécondé en laboratoire ont sauvé site de
la mer avec les spermatozoïdes du père
au troisième jour de développement des
embryons
on a prélevé sur chacun d'eux une
cellule le but c'était de sélectionner
les embryons dont les futurs organes et
tissus seraient génétiquement compatible
avec ceux de marcus un de ces embryons a
été implanté dans l'utérus de la mère
dans quelques semaines naîtra un enfant
dont on récupérera dès la naissance le
sang du cordon ombilical
ce sens est en effet riche en cellules
souches qui pourraient être capable de
remplacer les cellules malades de marcus
cette technique n'est pratiqué
actuellement qu aux etats unis elle est
interdite en europe
et pourtant certains spécialistes
voudrait l'a pratiqué en angleterre le
rôle de la médecine c'est de prévenir
les maladies pas d'attendre qu'elle soit
là pour essayer de les guérir et c'est
ce que nous faisons avec cette technique
est en octobre 2000 molly nash a reçu
les cellules de son frère adam les
peeters espérait aussi pouvoir un jour
sauver le petit marcus avec ce bébé leur
quatrième enfant